c'est le mariage de l'année dans le
secteur de l'informatique ibm et apple
signe un accord pour les années 90 une
alliance qui était encore inimaginable
il ya seulement quelques mois un mariage
en fait de raison dans une conjoncture
de plus en plus difficile ibm c'est le
géant et le numéro un mondial
apple lui avaient été créés dans un
garage par deux génies de l'informatique
martin cpo l'alliance de ibm et apple
c'est l'histoire de deux pionniers de
l'informatique devenus deux géants mais
aussi deux ennemis deux ennemis de
toujours qui doivent aujourd'hui s'unir
pour faire face ensemble à la crise
mondiale de l'informatique pour la
première fois de son histoire
ibm le numéro un mondial a cette année
essuyé des pertes
la vente de micro ordinateurs n'est plus
assez rentable les prix doivent être
toujours plus brader pour faire face à
la concurrence asiatique
alors changement de cap le splendide
isolement
c'est terminé faire front ensemble de sa
veut désormais dire harmoniser les
standards du matériel éditer des
logiciels compatibles sur les micro des
deux fabricants
enfin mettre en commun recherche
technologie pour développer les micro
ordinateurs de demain d ordinateur
intelligent
l'alliance entre ibm et apple n'est que
technologique
mais elle ouvre la voie à une nouvelle
ère de l'informatique
l'ère des méga regroupement